son inhalateur et son concentrateur
d'oxygène sont toujours près de lui
la vie quotidienne épuise rapidement ils
vont cousineau les bonnes journées
séquence grouille pas tellement car je
compte mativi je me lève juste car c'est
nécessaire ça peut être dès le 28 mars
dernier ce retraité de 61 ans est devenu
l'un des premiers canadiens atteints de
l'aco vide après être rentré de vacances
passées à cuba mais il n'en garde aucun
souvenir
émond et tu es sciences puis m'ont
transféré en hélicoptère puis de leurs
rangers towa mais mireille ont lâché
deux marchés où ils y arrêtaient de
marché que le e-mo mis sous dialyse
mais mon système d'après d'après fermé
ils ont essayé de m'enlever l'éducation
parce que j'étais dans le coma pendant
cette semaine ils vont cousineau a
finalement pu rentrer à la maison en
septembre après cinq mois et demi
d'hospitalisation dans son salon seront
les photos de ses quatre petits enfants
son inspiration j'avais des portraits de
mes dix ans à faire là ma chambre à
l'hôpital
à chaque fois que je me réveillais vais
je voyais que c'est quelque chose que
j'ai pour ce travail à cause d'eux au
puy ma femme
les lésions sur ses poumons sont
permanentes il fait de la physiothérapie
trois fois par semaine d'exercices que
je fais pour mes premiers commencent à
créer des lits qu'est ce qui amènerait
au poumon
mais mes poumons il ya une guerre et
rompre les rangs tout est restée secrète
il s'est séparé comme si j'ai pas de
deuxième souffle des images de
manifestations anti masque yvon
cousineau s'indigne de ce qu'il voit aux
nouvelles par moments et groix que si
les canadiens avaient été plus prudents
les rassemblements défaite aurait pu
être permis que donc c'est pas le
gouvernement
coq noël c'est aux autres membres
que jean mouro terre d'être un vrai
cette année je me foutais c'est ici que
qui manque du monde à noël l'année
prochaine sa vie et celle de sa
conjointe sont bouleversé à jamais mais
yvon cousineau s'estime chanceux malgré
tout ça d'accueil paix qu'elle soit
devra avoir des séquelles avec bataille
de muret j'aurais pu voir la misère à
marcher c'est bien et surtout il peut
continuer à voir grandir ses petits
enfants ici philippe leblanc radio
canada toronto